[Music]
the vampire and Lycan clans had been at
war for centuries turning our world into
a battlefield for me the fight is
personal everyone I've ever loved has
been hunted they're now a new war is
being waged Selene the lichens are
moving again they have a new leader
Marius I'm finished with this war well
it's not finished with you he wants the
blood of you and your daughter even I
don't know where she is I need you to
deliver a message tell your Marius I'm
coming for him
do you understand your message
who need saline and end the war she
cannot exist
she is the purest all muscle she is the
key the futures of lichens and vampires
and when we have the plant of saline and
her daughter it will be invincible Wow
Oh any vampire in this car you must help
me
protector you must go north you will
find answers there if you want to win
this war you will need to go further
than even a warrior of your renown has
ever ventured impossible
there's nothing stopping her now
there are too many of them do I look
worried
what I want is your blood
come & get it
the key will be in principle as the
lichens grow stronger